a reminder 8 news now is your election
headquarters we are now 12 days away
from election day and early voting is
still underway well today we caught up
with congresswoman Dina Titus as she
cast her in-person ballot and her
concern over her safety following the
attack on speaker Nancy Pelosi's husband
this morning
as election day draws near nevadans are
not holding back to cast their vote if
there's five ten minute wait even an
hour I do it I don't care it's my
privilege just like driving to vote
among the crowds on Friday was
democratic congresswoman Dina Titus and
her husband Tom placing the early vote
at the Boulevard Mall while praising the
workers standing by there we have these
great poll workers and they've been
harassed in parts of the country so
they're very brave to be out here on the
front lines the congresswoman who is up
for re-election against Republican Army
veteran and business owner Mark
Robertson speaking out about the
overnight attack on speaker Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul in San Francisco
it's very scary you know they have
advised all of us to get added security
around our homes I don't live in a gated
community I'm kind of wide open I
haven't felt threatened but that
certainly is a wake-up call nearly 20
thousand voters cast their ballots in
Clark County on the first weekend of
early voting in the 2022 general
election Robertson and tweeting this
picture a few days ago with the I voted
sticker for this mother-daughter team
preparation they say is also everyone's
responsibility everybody has an opinion
of whoever's running for whatever and to
me you really can't voice that opinion
if you don't vote I don't vote
necessarily for the party
but I vote for the person
who fits my needs and that I think is
best for America and for the state that
I'm living